did you see the r.kelly thing did you
see the our Kelly our Kelly in Ethiopia
I mean first first of all first of all I
sent this to the group chat and he goes
like this and and and Mike my opener who
like thinks about birds a lot flying
probably because he's [ __ ] there is
he goes oh it's fake and it made me mad
because he's just a [ __ ] nicer and
it's not fake and if you know anything
about he's like it looks doesn't look
like the the lyrics are matching up with
his mouth and imma but you got to
understand they were filming it in a
[ __ ] arena so they got the reverb in
the [ __ ] the time delay and all the
[ __ ] and you got to understand you got
to know are Kelly you got to be smarter
than that and know about what art Kelly
would do and this is right in line with
what he would do if you haven't heard
this I'm gonna play it for you
now our Kelly is a bad guy obviously he
pisses on fourteen-year-olds nothing
worse nothing worse okay but this guy if
he wasn't a bad guy and an actual good
guy
this would be the most illest song of
all time because it's s so basic and he
just says what he wants that's the thing
I like about R&B it's the thing I liked
about our Kelly songs too until I
realize he pissed on 12-year olds is
that it was so just like I'm in the
closet next to a parka and you'd be like
aw it doesn't mean anything that's just
what it is he's literally there so this
is what he sings to people in Ethiopia I
got it
say leadest okay first of all sings do
you haven't heard this oh wow I wouldn't
get rid of has not heard this oh oh dude
you're gonna love this bro
have you heard this oh yeah I showed it
to you I got it
do you have your passport he's an idiot
you get your shots girl would you like
to come back just to send it home and
other time said America the fact that he
calls himself Rob is really the icing on
the cake
like he's like look call me Rob No
[Music]
do you want to come back with I a
Shakespeare
[Music]
are back with are back with our went
back to our wasn't like got a little bit
too familiar with you it was like ah you
know what I shouldn't have told on my
real name dude
dude did I'm sorry the greatest lyrics
of all time did you get your shots like
a badass [ __ ] singing R&B but we
still got a [ __ ] play cool by the
government yeah
you still need your passport even though
I'm gonna do such dirty things you still
need your passport did you get your
shots and so soulful and you got to see
how many people are at this [ __ ] so
sexy R&B is literally the sexiest
[ __ ] I mean dude it's the sexiest
genre of music of music I always said
RMB is the best the best music and the
worst music but dude I'm sorry
sex is sexiest [ __ ] like this this rigor
so sexy you know
so nineties this song peaches and cream
[Music]
this is sexy this sexy want to put my
lips all over you peaches and cream and
then I mean son sexy thinking about a
[ __ ] girl in a doctor's office in
like it with like blinding [ __ ] neon
lights I want to make love to you but I
mean then there's this that song was
this [ __ ] huh peaches and cream well you
know what I mean did you get your shots
I mean if 112 just broke up and was like
hold up though did you get your shots
you'd be like what the [ __ ]
peaches and cream dude I'm sorry but did
you get your passport made my jaw drop
and then when he said [ __ ] did you
get your shots I had to pick it up off
the floor like the mask
what is this YouTube this isn't the
[ __ ] duty news